before we begin since this is a BBC
owned property I feel the need to point
out that the news armor the BBC has a
continuing issue with transphobic
leanings in its news coverage you can
find in a pinned comment below various
videos from both myself and other
YouTubers covering this issue and while
I understand that the Doctor Who
creative team is not responsible for
this I will continue to point this out
for as long as it remains a consistent
issue thank you
well we have gone through the Timeless
child escapades
let's see how the episode's sorted out
[Music]
yeah I do this after I revisit a series
let's rank the episodes
uh okay a couple things before I get
into this uh the first is is that next
week will be my take two review of
revolution of the Daleks but after that
tattoo reviews are gonna go on hold
again for a little bit there's two
reasons for this the first is I actually
want to put a little more distance
between the frustration of uh revisiting
the Timeless child Arc and also I want a
little more distance from my first
viewing of flux itself how far down the
line I'll pick it up again and do the
revisit I don't know right now because
the other reason is that
um I really have some other stuff that I
need to get done and have been trying to
get done for a while and I need the time
uh so I need to drop the Wednesday
videos for a bit and since take to a
doctor who's been occupying the
Wednesday slot it's going to go on hold
I will come back after resolution will
do flux we'll do the specials
we will just
not right away
but before we can even get to that
special we need to talk about these
episodes
this was a bit of a frustrating revisit
this series for me because and I think I
do still feel it is the best of the
chiminal era but
there were things I already knew I
didn't like and I found a whole bunch of
stuff that I'd either forgotten or
hadn't noticed the first time
that rubbed me up the wrong way again
and that's somewhat reflected in this
ranking there's only 10 episodes to
cover I am breaking spyfall into uh two
different things to consider since I did
review them separately start at the
bottom work our way up starting with
number 10
the Timeless children
uh yeah uh it was either gonna be this
or the next one but after revisiting
this episode and realizing that it
wasn't just a matter of the uh
Exposition that is given and everything
that implies about increasing the
importance of the doctor and all that
other stuff my old my old feeling was
like that is really bad but a lot of the
rest of stuff that's around it is is
fine there's nothing really wrong with
it that's that's not true it's not true
like that stuff is bad all the stuff in
the Matrix or I can't think of it as
anything other than the exposition
machine at this point all the stuff
related to that not only the information
given but the way it's given the way it
is presented not only to the doctor but
to us is is just bad it is a bad
presentation of what I already think is
a bad idea but almost everything else
around it is also bad about the only
good stuff or a couple of little tiny
moments like some little performance
moments from the master but that's it
that's it this was infuriatingly bad and
yeah it is the worst of this series
number nine
orphan 55. yeah yeah it shouldn't be a
huge shock now the thing is I'm not
actually as down on Orphan 55 as a lot
of people are I think it's ultimately a
issue of intent between the writing and
the production because there's a sense
of Camp to the writing into a lot of the
elements present but it's presented very
matter of factly straightforward and
seriously for most of it and it's the it
like it's a mess this is a mess but I do
have to wonder
is it a mess because it needed to be
handled on the production end in a way
that embraced the fact that it's kind of
dumb rather than trying to offset the
fact that it's kind of dumb which is
what it feels like it's doing would it
have been a good episode if they'd done
that I don't know I think it would have
been better than what we got though so
this gets above Timeless children
largely because I can Envision a way in
which it at least doesn't end up all the
way down here Timeless children I I at
this point it really does feel
unsalvageable without a complete from
the ground up rewrite
number eight
Ascension of the Cybermen again my
initial memory was that the setup
episode for the finale wasn't that bad
and it was just the finale that dropped
the ball it's it's not great though and
I mean part of this is the sins of what
comes later it's setting up stuff that
is really going to irritate me and so
it's hard to take much enjoyment from
what this episode presents since most of
what it's doing is all stuff that is
either going to go nowhere or go
somewhere that I don't like so despite a
shod continuing to be a really good
fascinating villain there just isn't a
lot here to salvage uh for me again
certainly better than what we get in The
Following episode but
yeah there just isn't really much that I
found enjoyment in here
number seven
the hunting of villa Dia Daddy yeah this
is this is going to be the the big
controversial placement I suspect look
it's not that the episode as a whole is
bad it's not it's actually got some of
the best production really great
presentation fantastic atmosphere really
good acting
but the things that it does that tick me
off are things that really really tick
me off so this is not a case of
everything you did was wrong this is a
case of the things that you did wrong at
least to my view and what I feel is
wrong about it are things that I hate so
much that it's going to drag the whole
thing down even with all this other good
stuff even with good performances even
with good direction even with solid
build and anticipation and atmosphere
and a shot getting introduced and again
he's really good
but the stuff that I can't stand the
focus on the great man of History
approach to how doctor who handles its
historicals some of the specific things
that she says reinforcing that the
complete disregard for the deaths of the
other people and it just reinforces
doctor whose worst habits about ignoring
Ordinary People while aggrandizing the
people recorded by history as if they
are the only ones who ever matter and I
hate that so much I cannot in good
conscience put this any higher even
though I recognize all its strengths
what it does wrong I just hate I hate it
number six
praxius
is fine
I mean it's kind of it it's fine it's
tackling some of the same things as uh
orphan 55 in terms of themes it handles
them better they're better integrated
um some of the effects are unsettling in
a way that I think works some other
effects really don't look very good at
all but I mean it's Doctor Who that's
kind of what you get
um some of the characters some of the
guest casts even have uh some decent
moments and Yaz gets some of her
stronger material in this I really did
completely forget the climax of this and
how it ended because it doesn't stick
with you at all like the strong stuff is
all kind of in the front end and maybe a
little in the middle and it's not that
it falls apart but it just kind of turns
into White Noise by the end
number five
spyfall part two
so this uh is a case where there's the
good stuff there's the bad stuff and
there's that almost an even mix of it
and in this case the bad stuff isn't
really bad it's just uh an unfortunate
set of priorities because dewan's stuff
the master in this I think is really
good the problem is this is the second
part of a story where the master was
only introduced at the very end of the
previous episode
and that he then completely dominates
this half and it
it loses track of what else it's doing
it doesn't manage to really get in there
and pay off a whole bunch of the other
stuff that was set up which was most of
the previous episode it just deals with
it very haphazardly very offhandedly
because the doctor kind of not the
doctor the master uh kind of devours the
story and as much as I like the master I
kind of wanted to see where the actual
narrative was going to go and he takes
it over so much that I do have to kind
of knock it down a little bit for that
number four
okay now we're into the stuff that I do
think is like it's good it's good not
too many reservations it's good Nikola
Tesla's Knight of Terror this was
definitely better than I remembered it I
remembered it being kind of forgettable
but it's uh it's use of its theming and
its integrating of these specific
historical figure well multiple
historical figures into the way that it
is approaching the villains and how
things are going with the doctor and the
surprising amount of depth given to
someone like Edison even though he is
kind of an antagonist within the
narrative yeah this is one of the better
historicals I would say of the modern
era Doctor Who Run overall and as well
as being one of the best of this run
absolutely but it's it's really solid
it's a lot stronger than I had given it
credit for before not too much really
blows me away about it but sometimes
just having something really solidly put
together good performances good moments
the themes and the uh overall things in
you the points you're going for are all
knitted together well
I I can't be upset about that
number three
spyfall part one I do think this is
actually a really strong setup and it's
got a really great Cliffhanger I am
choosing to not drag it down too much
for knowing that the big reveal of the
master at the end kind of destroys the
narrative when we get into the second
half or at least takes it over but
setting that aside as an episode unto
itself as a setup as a start to the
series as an introduction to a different
feel with the Spy related stuff to the
weirdness of the aliens to just the
overall sort of moving forward in the
James bondiness of it of certain moments
like the soundtrack and the gadgets on
it's like this is just fun this is good
fun it's a good setup it made me really
want the next episode and that's the job
of the first half of two-parter and it
did its job
number two
fugitive of the jedune you know what
even now knowing that the fugitive
doctor goes almost nowhere
does not get properly delved into paid
off doesn't feel particularly rewarding
it speaks to how much I love Joe Martin
doing this part that this is as high as
it is and that said the way the reveal
is handled despite some aspects of the
revealed not making a lot of sense but
honestly things like not explaining why
this doctor's Tardis is a uh is a police
box and not figuring out where she falls
uh within the time frame and then later
on we have the clear clear implication
that she's pre-hardinal and all that
like those are problems I feel like with
the series overall and how she was
handled overall not specific to this
episode because I don't think it was
this episode's obligation to answer all
of those I do think it was the series
obligation to eventually answer some of
them but
different issues within this episode
itself Joe Martin Nails it she's great
as Ruth and then she's great as the
doctor and this is just a fun ride even
knowing that ultimately almost
everything that it sets up in this goes
nowhere I still enjoy revisiting it it's
fun I like it
number one
can you hear me and I know I'm a little
bit of a defender of this one uh
compared to some other people's feelings
about it I still think it's fantastic I
really like the way that it handles its
uh its allegory and its metaphor in
terms of mental health and depression is
it on the nose yeah a bit but I still
think it's well thought out enough that
I really enjoy it I love the concepts of
these antagonists I like the way that
just the whole thing progresses and
moves forward and there's this
unsettling atmosphere in the sense that
the doctors really truly up against
something that is out of her League
which is not something we get that
feeling for all that often anymore and
it was quite enjoyable for that and I
still like it it's probably the episode
of the chiminal era I've rewatched the
most and knowing that my tendency to
re-watch often means I find new problems
this continues to hold up watch after
watch view after view I still really
like it I think it's really good I know
not everyone does and if you want to
hear the my reasons for it you know or
my reasons for any of these really check
the individual reviews out but I think
this is still really great episode
so uh that's my thoughts on series 12.
once I get through flux and the specials
I suppose I have to do a ranking of uh
the best of the chiminal era overall
best and worst maybe I gotta figure out
if I'm gonna do best and worst of the
overall era or best and worse of
chimnell as a writer because if I do
that I'm going to have to integrate the
stuff he did prior to being showrunner
and or possibly Torchwood I'd have to
decide about that I don't know I gotta
figure it out these are things for
future me to worry about but present me
is done for right now and wants to know
what do you think about this what would
your ranking be whatever your thoughts
are drop something down the comments
let's talk about it patreon pays the
bills and enables me to do this as my
living any amount you can give me is of
great assistance and there are perks at
every support here but even if you can't
like share subscribe also help me out
there's links in the description for
other things that I do where you can
check out my other works but don't worry
too much about it because what I really
want you to remember is that you are
beautiful
you're valid
you are loved
you are the council I'm just running the
meetings and until next time this
council is adjourned
[Music]
and now my thanks to my highest
supporters on patreon Robin Moore Zuma
fulla to rock the thing that goes doing
in the anime Oliver B Melinda Walters
emu dalke Leo the Boyd Becky Sparks for
Nobby LAX the poodle
Tracy Scrabble angry Casper Tim price
Adam RDL Taylor Shayla gourlay and
Rosalind Bennett
thanks for your support
and if you want to get your name in the
credits check out the rewards on the
patreon
[Music]